everything behind me right now is the
forest that I've been working to protect
for the last 13 years it's burning like
this every day and if you think our
planet can survive this every day in the
Amazon you have another thing coming
[Music]
the people that are burning the forest
are Brazilians and you know or Peruvians
or whatever whatever country you're in
across the Amazon it's not the
indigenous people the indigenous types
are are for the most protecting their
forests since these outside other
citizens of these countries that are
coming in and sort of invading
indigenous lands
[Music]
this is not just an Amazonian issue
don't forget we're losing forests in
Indonesia
we're losing forests and New Guinea
we're losing forests in the Congo in
Africa it's all over the world if if
someone was to go into you know New York
City and and destroy a building they'd
be in jail the rest of their lives but
we can go and destroy a river that
sustains millions and millions of people
and a few guys get rich and everyone
else is made poor and that's not
considered a crime so we need to update
our software on how we've got these
things because it's all wrong
[Music]
this has to be systemic change it has to
be that that we don't elect leaders
without good environmental policy that
we no longer allow corporations to get
rich while millions of people that are
tied to the land get more poor we asked
I mean we have this power we have the
ability to stop this that's the crazy
thing is that at the end of the day not
cutting down trees isn't rocket science